there's so many of your cast members are
here what does it mean that as a group
you are here tonight I mean so much it
means that we as an issue community I
represent so we're all dying to know
because we love the movie so much
what's the latest on a sequel well they
are in the midst of writing - you're
excited about having a two in three
there's no host tonight but there are
hosts of presenters and you are one of
them and I also think it's important
that you get to walk out on that stage
and you know all over the world people
will be watching and they will say there
is someone like me walking out you guys
get together tonight collectively as a
group what are you doing well wanna
brothers is throwing off to Oscar party
give us a good chance to celebrate a
star is born but we they'll bring in
some some of that golden guy home and
then the crazy rich family is here as
well
what are you wearing I'm wearing a sock
[Music]
you're so known for your jewelry and the
Newbery you are known jewelry or isaburo
it's a kill tonight but and Rashad knew
it was the most difficult thing about
navigating this dress
there's no one stepping on the chair and
then although our people do that it's
usually the men they do that if you
notice when men don't pay attention
that's the problem men aren't looking
they don't understand they don't
understand what it takes to and and you
don't wear heels I'm actually gonna make
a bed if anybody steps on your train
tonight it will be a fella we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]